do you remember when we fill out the
table in the first place we had a sign
rule here and we have a sidewalk here
it's the same rule but what's the
difference
it's just upside down because the
subject is a little different okay it's
the same thing with this I can use this
rule to find out an angle instead of a
sign if I want how am I going to do it
do you remember that last question that
you did in the quiz today what was that
about it was not changing the subject
right this is not the subject at the
moment this is but I wanted to be the
subject so underneath where you've
written this write down cosine rule for
angels I hope you are okay if I want cos
C to be the subjects I've got to get it
away from everything else by itself so
here's the first thing I'm going to do
see how it's um it's negative which is a
big gross okay I'm gonna add to a
because C to both sides
okay and then it would no longer be
negative over here so what that leaves
me read is this
okay with that so all I've done is I
don't want it to be a negative because I
want clothes see by itself and positive
so add it to both sides
nothing dramatic yeah okay but there's
this pesky C squared there so how am I
gonna get into that hey I want to
subtract it from both sides so if I do
that on the left hand side I just get
left with this right i subtracted it and
on the right hand side if I write it in
alphabetical order I get that so far so
good
okay really really have one more step to
go you see I've got to a b x plus c
don't want the two a B so what should I
do
we divide both sides by 2 a B on the
left hand side it just leaves me with
nothing and on the right hand side it's
going to be on the bottom okay now this
is a bit of a mouthful this is one of
the reasons why it's on the formula in a
datasheet this is also on the formality
and you already know the same rule and
the area of a triangle they're all on
the formula and datasheet remembering
it's not the hard part understanding and
using it is okay so let me give you an
example can you turn in your textbook so
fiber
let's do one aim that's it simple as it
gets you really can't actually simplify
much from there
okay and so if you want to put a box
around it that's the cosine rule for
science
there's the cosine rule for angles same
rule just dressed up a little different
please each other
[Music]
okay this is kind of funny because this
is um this is what's and you suggested
so he's my example one day I'm just
gonna to get up yeah I'm trying to find
X what kind of value is it aside really
sorry Saturday so siren ankle it's a
slide okay so therefore I'm going to use
the cosine row in this form rather than
that one okay now just like with the
same rule it's important that you know
where stuff is have a look here there
are one two three sides but what you
want is the one you're gonna put over
here in the middle x squared
do you see I'm just substituting into
this right now
that's right so is what I want to find
these are the other two sides and
they're does it matter which one day
which ones be it doesn't because you do
the same thing to both of them both of
them to get squared squared is back both
them get multiplied in the same thing a
and B to a be right there
so therefore actually with these two
guys over here
they're cut interchangeable which is
nice so I'm just gonna write that out 9
squared plus 10 squared - I'm still
substituting to the formula right now to
a big cause now this is the very first
question so they've deliberately made it
easy for you there's only one angle so
you put that angle in however it's not
just any angle it's the included angle
just like for the area of a triangle how
did you know was the include like if I
gave you
okay now look carefully yes
see how it's that letter and it's
opposite this one which is the one
you're trying to find do you see its
opposite right which means it must be
between the others hence included okay
so if I gave you 120 and 60 this is how
you got it oh no no no it's the one
that's included between the northern
side so okay that's just a substitution
I know it looks messy but the calculator
will do all of this for us okay go ahead
reach for your calculator okay good now
just like with Pythagoras remember this
is basically souped-up Pythagoras right
Pythagoras doesn't give you the length
straightaway it gives you the square of
the length so I have to do one more
thing just take the square root
it's nothing you can't do
tada they go no triangles necessary you
just have to be careful with you such as
you know okay
I'm gonna show you what four angles have
a look at to a this time I I want to
make sure I know diem for the first one
is that the numbers right okay help me
out I want to find this angle I can use
the cosine rule I'm going to start just
by substituting what I know because
there now I'm gonna rehearse the
question I asked before remember any
even will find this side did it matter
which one was any which one was big it
didn't matter because Eggert square and
so does big a gets multiplied to here
and so does big but look at see do you
see that see do you notice that C is
different you do something different to
say that you don't do the ambience
you've got to know which one it is you
get the order wrong you're in trouble
which one is C remember when we name
sides and angles we said Big C and
little C they're opposite each other
right so have a look can you see men I
mean it's just another way sorry do you
notice 14 is the right
okay that's it so now I can substitute
it's not say hot right can I get a
decimal place so I'm gonna crunch that
is anyone punch the contraction already
can I have a few places please can I get
some confirmation just anyone else get
this thumbs up yeah great excellent now
just like with the sign room yeah that's
not the angle that's what being go you
have to go shift cause and that'll do
you is that cut around to that yeah
now here's what's wonderful at the curse
on you remember I told you the Simon has
this unintended problem which is like
yeah it could be 33 or it might be
something else right it ambiguous the
cosine rule has no ambiguity it has to
be 33 if it's an obtuse angle it will
actually tell you the into Sabres which
is great right
in fact just as an example suppose we
thought the duck after some working you
got to this okay sorry it's a bit messy
suppose you'd punched it all in and
after you evaluated that fraction you've
got this
just punch negative zero point one three
and you calculate you just go ahead and
do it then once you've got that decimal
Bay you want the angle don't you so what
do you press do you press shift cause
and then it tells you it automatically
knows if it's obtuse or not so much more
awesome which is why if you have a
choice don't get into that later you
have a choice you use the cursor okay